How do holograms work?
If I said magic, would you believe me?
Okay, fine.
Holography is the practice of recording an interference pattern using coherent light within a holographic substrate.
What does that mean?
Number one, interference pattern.
Think of the light waves like water waves, right?
Waves be waving.
Simple example, I throw two rocks into the water, and what happens?
We get ripples.
Whoa, those are waves, right?
All right, so this thing you're looking at here with the ripple ripples, this is a wavefront, okay?
Now, all these little points in which the waves are intersecting, basically these coherent light waves are intersecting,
these little tiny little points, those are interference points.
And you might be thinking, Travis, what do these two rocks have to do with anything?
It's just a good starting point.
So, now we understand wave interference, right?
On a two-dimensional aquatic plane, sure.
Not the three-dimensional photonic plane.
So, expand the two-dimensional concept of the water waves into the three-dimensional realm.
I think it's kind of crazy.
So, let's talk about how the light, a single photon would act, right?
We shoot a photon out of a laser beam, and it's going to hit the holographic film first.
This is a single beam method.
There's different ways to do this.
But it hits the film first, hits the subject, right?
The subject is not going to be perfectly smooth, so it's going to scatter that photon.
So, we have like a cone of light, right?
And the cone is going to come back into the film, all right?
That's the other wave.
We got the wave shooting in.
We got the wave coming back out.
And now, inside of that holographic film that's in between that wave pattern, we're going to basically record our interference pattern, our interference point.
So, we do that about a billion times across the entire surface of the film because that's just how organic capturing of film works.
And now you have a matrix of, you know, billions of interference points that are all reconstructing an image.
Because of those interference points during the development process, basically you have metallic particles that are going to align.
And become silvered, so to speak, or refractive.
And that's how you get your holographic light effect.
Because the light is coming in, it's going to reflect some back.
But also focus it like a lens do, right?
And that's how we get our shape.
So, much like creating a sculpted toy and making a cast of it and making a mold, it's kind of like making a holographic mold.
But you don't fill it with plastic or resin, you fill it with light, and then it replays the original interference pattern.
Let's record it.
That's just my, that's just off my dome here.
I, there's, there's search engines?
Yeah, you know what I'm talking about.
You can, you, as, you can read.
You can read about it.